Another trick to aiding our ability to recall previously learned information,
is by using a mnemonic device. A mnemonic device is a method to help us
remember information. For example, we may come up with a rhyme to remember
something or perhaps an acronym. So, if we have to remember the grocery list
that we made earlier in the lesson, this one. We can circle the first letter of
each of the items, and come up with an acronym. We gave you a pneumonic device
in lesson 2, when we where describing how to remember the difference between an
independent and a dependent variable. We told you to remember that the
independent variable starts with an I, and investigator starts with an I. So
it's the investigator that manipulates the independent variable. That was a
mnemonic device.